- 嗨,大家好
平常如果我們想要用AI來生成圖片或影片
最常見的方式就是訂閱各種線上的AI平台
不過這些服務每個月可能都要固定支付10至15美元以上
部分進階的方案甚至更貴
這對於只是偶爾使用
或是單純想要體驗AI創作的用戶來說
是一個不小的負擔
因此今天我要向大家介紹一個更具彈性的方式
就是在自己的AI助理
像是ChatGPT或Cloud
安裝一個Scale技能
讓AI助理能以非常低廉的成本來生成圖片和影片
不需要綁定任何的訂閱方案
好,那這邊我們首先要下載Cloud或ChatGPT的桌面板軟體
因為後續我們需要讓AI助理讀取參考圖片
並且將生存好的檔案儲存到指定的位置
而如果你習慣使用ChatGPT
你也可以在它的官網首頁來下載它的桌面板軟體
好,那我以Cloud 為例
下載並安裝完成後
你可以直接把桌面板的軟體打開
而這邊我們需要在電腦中先建立一個專案資料夾
你可以隨意找一個位置
利用滑鼠優件執行新增
並取一個自己容易記住的名字
建立好後
我們對著資料夾雙擊滑鼠左鍵來將它打開
並且重複剛才的步驟
另外建立兩個資料夾
分別是完成檔和參考圖
之後我們會使用到
資料夾準備好之後
你就可以回到桌面板的軟體
來加目前的專案指定到剛建立的資料夾
點擊打開
再一下信任此工作區
如果你使用的是ChatGPT
方式也大同小異
你只要把來源資料夾
同樣指定到剛才的位置就OK了
好,那接下來我們要來到一個叫做Fold的平台
它的優點是提供的AI模型非常的多
所以寄費方式非常的透明
你可以用自己的Gmail信箱先註冊一個帳號
登入之後
我們要取得一個叫做 API Key 的金鑰
系統會使用這把金鑰來辨識你是哪一位使用者
好 所以我們到右上角點擊新增金鑰
點擊建立
然後你就可以把螢幕上顯示的金鑰密碼拷貝下來
妥善保存在自己的電腦
那FOR不需要你支付固定的月費
而是按照你實際生成的圖片數量來計算費用
因此我們必須先綁定一張信用卡
綁定完成後切換到Credits的頁面
那一開始其實不需要儲值太多
你可以等熟悉操作之後
再試自己的需求來增加額度
而要查看FOR有提供哪些AI模型
你可以到左上角點擊探索
如此你就能在頁面左側看到所有的模型分類
例如Text to Image
就是所謂的由文字生成圖片
那目前文森圖的AI模型
其中最受歡迎的一個
是由Google 推出的Nano Banana Tool
那這個頁面有提供了一個簡單的範例
左側的Prompt 欄位是這張圖使用的提示詞
然後下面有一個寬告筆的下拉選單
再來是影像的解析度
在旁邊有一個進階設定的按鈕你可以在這個區塊指定生成圖片的數量以及图檔要採用哪一種儲存格式最後在右欄有一項很重要的資訊就是在使用Nano Banana Tool的時候
費用是如何計算的
你可以把這些資訊做個拷貝
來跟其他AI模型做個比較
譬如目前另一個很熱門的AI模型是GPT Image Tool
你可以進入它的頁面之後
同樣找到它的計價方式
把它拷貝下來
然後我們就可以在ChatGPT把兩個模型的價目表貼上去
請他來做個分析
看看哪個比較划算
好,那分析的結果
ChatGPT認為使用Nano Banana 2來生的圖片會比較省錢
所以我打算把它當成主力的模型
接著再回到Fall的官網
將Nano Banana 2的模型ID做個複製
那這邊有個要注意的地方
就是Fall提醒我們
一個模型可能會使用不同的接口來執行不同的任務
以Nano Banana來說,它有兩個接口
一個是文字生成圖片
而另一個是修改現有的圖片
至於GPT Image Tool 這邊也是一樣的
總共有兩個不同的接口
好,取得了 API 金曜和模型的 ID 之後
我們可以回到 Cloud 準備來建立一個 Scale 技能
所謂技能
你可以把它當成是一個讓 AI 助理閱讀的操作手冊
讓他知道在執行任務時要遵守哪些要點
舉例來說 我們可以告訴Cloud
只要我們請他生成或編輯圖片
就要啟用這個技能
使用的模型包含了Nano Banana Tool 和 GPT Image Tool
同時要提醒他必須依照任務的類型來選擇正確的接口
那這邊還有一點要特別注意
就是我們剛才取得的 API 金鑰不要直接貼給Cloud
因為這有可能會讓金鑰隨著對話內容一同曝光到網路上
比較合適的做法是把這類型的機密資訊
儲存在一個叫做 .env 的檔案
讓程式在執行時自動讀取
那最後我們也要在提示詞中說明
如果生成的任務需要用到參考圖
AI助理可以到參考圖資料夾內來存取這些檔案
至於生成好的圖片
則統一放到完成檔資料夾
並且以模型名稱加上日期時間來作為檔名
好,那我把這個提示詞貼到輸入框內
並且按下 Enter 鍵送出
CRAWD 有可能會在建立技能的過程中
向我们询问一些问题
你可以依照自己的需求来进行作答
也可以直接采用他提供的建议
等技能建立完成后
你就可以打开Cloud
替我们准备好的.env档案
让大家显示在电脑的资料夹内
接着再加上这个档案
使用一般的记事本开启
来将先前我们取得的API金钥贴到指定的位置
最后再按下Ctrl加S执行储存
好
那我们就来测试一下建立好的技能吧
我請Cloud 生成一張圖片
主題是一個在古羅馬經濟場分擔的角鬥士
然後將提示詞送出
過程中如果跳出授權的對話框
就直接按下允許
於是過了一會兒之後
一張手持劍頓的角鬥士圖片就生成完畢了
而且圖片也已自動儲存到先前我們指定的資料夾
Ok 那接著我們來試試看
讓AI修改現有的圖片舉例來說這裡我有一張獅子的圖片我想要讓他穿上一套金色的鎧甲我要讓Cloud 能取得這張圖片我們必須先把圖檔拷貝起來
進入到專案中的參考圖資料夾
然後按下Ctrl-V 來將圖檔貼上
參考圖放到定位之後
你可以回到Cloud 來撰寫生成圖片的提示詞
如果有需要
你甚至可以請Cloud 使用不同的模型各生成一張圖片
方便我們對照兩個模型輸出圖片的風格特色
好,我們將提示詞送出
Shardy片刻後
Club 便回傳了兩張生日好的獅子圖片
甚至還貼心說明了兩個作品在細節上的差異喔
好,當我們在撰寫圖片提示詞時
常會遇到一個瓶頸
就是我們不知道該如何描述畫面中的細節
像是場景該如何鋪陳
鏡頭視角該如何拿捏等
而這種需要專業知識的任務
其實我們也可以交給AI助理來代勞
就是把原來的技能做個改寫
請拿在生成圖片時
先依據我們提供的主題自動補充更豐富的細節
而且修改好後要先讓我們過目
確認沒有問題之後才能送出
OK 技能修改完成後
我們來驗收一下成果
譬如我請Cloud生成一張蘇格拉底
在雅典街頭與別人辯論的圖片
然後將提示詞送出
而這一次Cloud並沒有直接動工
而是先把這個主題擴展成一段內容詳盡的提示詞
包含了人物的神態、周圍的建築
乃至於鏡頭的焦段等全都描述的一清二楚
而我們看過覺得沒有什麼問題的話
就可以請Cloud 送出
於是很快的
一張生動的蘇格拉底辯論的場景就呈現在我們的眼前囉
OK 那這個技能不光是可用來生成圖片
如果想要生成影片也沒有任何問題
我們一樣可以回到Ford的網站
在左側的分類中勾選Text to Video
以目前來說
生成影片效果最出色的模型首推Stead Dance 2.0
而旁邊的MiniMax H3
則是前幾天才剛亮相的新模型
除此之外
下面還有一個性價比很不錯的選擇是Clean V3
那同樣的
你可以逐一進入這幾個模型的頁面
把他們的機家資訊拷貝下來
一同交給AI來進行分析和比較
等你選定好綜藝的主力模型之後
你就可以寫一段提示詞
請Cloud 把影片生成的功能
一併加入到原有的技能之中
而由於影片的設定參數較多
而且每個模型的數值都不太一樣
因此這邊我讓Cloud 採用一問一答的方式
協助我們來進行設定
好,我將提示詞送出
功能一切就緒之後
就可以立即來做個測試
例如我指定用 Clean 3.0 生成一段影片
讓一位穿著時尚的男子朝著鏡頭走過來
然後拿出一條巧克力棒咬了一口
接著按下Enter鍵送出
同樣的
Cloud會根據這個主題先進行提示時的優化
我們看過沒有問題之後
Cloud就會開始逐一詢問影片參數的細節
包含影片的秒數
範高比要設為多少
以及是否要生成音訊
全部確認完畢後
Cloud就會開始進行影片的生成
好,我們來看一下生成好的作品
OK 那在生成影片時有一個很常見的技巧
就是我們先提供一張靜態的圖片作為初始影格
然後請AI將這張圖片動起來
那我們來看一個例子
譬如這裡有一張圖片
是一名女子將臉頰貼在一條巨大的飛龍頭上
而我想要讓AI延伸出後續的畫面
同樣的,我們要先把這張圖片做個拷貝
進入到參考圖資料夾
按下Ctrl-V 來將它貼上
然後我們再回到Cloud的介面來撰寫提示詞
比如這一次我改用MiniMax H3的模型
讓女子抬起頭跟飛龍一同看向相機的鏡頭
並且將鏡頭逐漸拉遠
然後按下Enter鍵送出
那Cloud同樣會先替我們優化提示詞的內容
来扩展影片中的细节
接着再向我们逐一确认影片的各项参数
包含长度要设为几秒
解析度要设为多高
确认完毕后
Cloud就开始执行影片生成的任务
于是片刻之后
一段充满史诗感的奇幻短片就成功产生
OK 最后如果你想要让生成图片和影片的流程更加顺手
我们甚至还可以更进一步
请Cloud把这个技能改造成一个桌面板的App
由于这是一个比较大的任务
所以你可以把Cloud先切换成计划模式
接着再来描述我们心目中理想的App样貌
像是四窗版面的布局
想要走什么样的设计风格
面板内应该有哪些栏位和按钮
以及生成好的作品要如何呈现和管理等
把这些想法送出之后
Cloud会询问我们一些问题来确认实作的细节
如果你对于技术层面的术语不太熟悉
可以直接采用Target的建议就OK了
细节都确认完毕之后
Cloud会先写一份计划的提案
看过之后如果没有问题
Cloud就会开始着手实作
好那APP目前已制作完成
我们可以把它打开实际来测试一下
首先API金钥的部分
你只要打开设定对话框
都能把金钥贴到栏位里面来做妥善的保存
而在界面的左上角
我们可以自由切换图片和影片两个分页
至于要使用哪一个AI模型
这个透过底下的下拉选单来做挑选
由于这个APP目前还缺少一个专属的图示
所以我们不妨借着这个机会
让APP自己来生成
例如我想要生成一个抽象几何风格
带有圆角造型的白色图示
宽高笔的话可以设成1比1
然后按下生成按钮
图示生成完毕后
我们就把它储存到电脑资料夹
并且将它命名为icon
那最后我们就让Cloud
把这个App的外观套用刚制作好的图示
并且将App安装到应用程式资料夹
如此一来
之后当我们想要生成图片或影片的时候
只要在电脑内打开这个App
就能立即使用
是不是非常的方便呢
OK
那今天关于Cloud生成图片和影片技能的介绍
我们就聊到这边
我们下回再见
拜拜
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目